since covid no longer shocks
bring in the monkey pox
yeah they're trying to prepare us for a
new disease to scare us
it's chimpish advice from the cdc
where a mask can stay out of trees
so the cdc raised the monkey pox alert
to level two yesterday upgrading from
marmoset to baboon
recommending that travelers wear masks
to avoid catching it
but then they later removed the mask
recommendation probably after they
realized it primarily spreads through
skin-to-skin contact that's putting it
politely
there are three total advisory levels
one being the lowest and three the
highest they use this system because
biden can no longer count to four
now this panic is being served up
despite the fact that most cases have
been linked to random sex at european
raves where i'm fairly sure the
participant's lack of mast was not their
highest risk behavior
fyi those leather masks they gave out
were completely useless
but i'm still wearing mine around the
house when i'm dusting my figurines
and eddie
in any case
no one is more excited about all of this
than anthony fauci who spent the weekend
ironing all his dress shirts and ties in
the hopes that tv networks will finally
start asking him back
what will be what will he be wrong about
this time china eating monkeys who knows
meanwhile the cdc's newest head doctor
held a press conference to clear up any
confusion
[Laughter]
doctor doctor can vaccinated people have
sex with monkeys
but what if it's awesome can't we just
wear masks while having sex with the
monkeys
doctor what if i give you a banana first
then could we have sex
[Applause]
that might be the best thing we've ever
done
[Laughter]
it's so hard to get scared of something
that sounds so adorable oh eyebox i
disagree
cause i'm on the one hand i'm not that
worried about it on the other hand it's
a pox yes and that's just like ew yeah
i'm not a scientist but i did spend like
three hours reading about it and i don't
want it
yeah there's a lot of boxes out there i
put that in my bottom tent hawks and
then like you have to stay home for
three weeks with your face all covered
in pox yeah but it's i don't think it's
on your face well
from what from the pictures i saw okay
that i took there's conflicting reports
all right and i just feel like
statistics don't mean much to me when it
comes to medical
abnormalities i'll probably get the
monkey box
poor thing probably will valuables
she can't get away with the one outlier
how'd she get the box we don't know but
she's got it real bad she'll get a text
from a monkey
look behind you isn't it funny how the
cdc really can't really couldn't say how
to spread it because that would be
politically incorrect you're reading my
mind that
once you make medicine political
you can no longer give a message yeah
this whole thing where doctors have to
be soothing and kind and respect
everyone's
wishes and pronouns is you're a doctor
you're a learner of science
say it how do you get it yeah who needs
to be most concerned with it
yeah and it's uncomfortable and i'm
sorry and
if you get it
no one around you isn't gonna know how
you got it yeah you know
[Applause]
p.a.b
welcome back to the show let's talk
about monkey pox
welcome i think it's spread through anal
sex with strangers you meet at a music
festival care to comment
[Laughter]
hey there
someone's looking at me
the cdc
yes why did they recommend masks in the
first place they know it's not airborne
they can see that in very close intimate
contact there could be respiratory
spread but they're talking about
intimate contact so it just seems like
they were spreading a panic by even
telling people and they did it you know
with the the whole covid saying less
than 10 of covid cases are transmitted
outdoors it turned out the actual number
was like .001
i mean technically it was accurate but
it's intellectually dishonest and also i
don't think anybody ever died from
outdoor exposure to to covid and we
should and that just totally screwed we
could have done so much outdoor stuff at
raves
how many raves i missed because of the
whole covet thing as if we didn't back
i was meeting this orangutang in london
oh god and we were just gonna party hard
we had some map
well look
i'm gonna rewrite the cdc memo for
everybody's benefit okay so step one
a don't a monkey
are you writing this down
are you out on this down
this is gold write this down step two
don't have random sex at european rapes
yes there you go
i don't know about u.s raves
or
latin raves yeah uh but i'm pretty sure
about the european ones yes exactly so
uh that's and then i would close off the
memo by saying sincerely mike
you know you're if there's one thing we
could say about you mike it's that
you're polite and you're sincere i am
yes you are hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else